l'italie coupé du monde compte ses morts
au cimetière de bergamo en reçoit les
cercueils
alors que le pays a aussi interdit les
funérailles le premier ministre comparé
l'épidémie à un raz-de-marée en gala
merkel demandent aux allemands de
renoncer au voyage à l'intérieur du pays
et à l'étranger à la frontière avec la
pologne
on contrôle la température de chaque
visiteur des dizaines de camions sont
bloqués en état d' alerte l'espagne a
fermé ses frontières terrestres
selon les autorités le confinement de 46
millions d'espagnols risque de durer
dans les rues de madrid ville la plus
touchée
la police est là pour faire respecter
les restrictions de déplacements réunion
d'urgence au cabinet britannique après
avoir misé sur la diffusion lente du
virus qui aurait permis de développer
une humilité
boris johnson demande auprès d'annick de
cesser les contacts et les déplacements
non essentiels
il préconise le télétravail et demande
aux citoyens d'éviter les lieux de
rassemblements but alors que l'europe
connaît une flambée de l'épidémie
la chine enregistre une baisse
significative du nombre de personnes
atteintes
durant les derniers jours c'est auprès
des voyageurs que l'on recense le plus
de cas pékin a donc instauré la
quarantaine pour les visiteurs
internationaux en corée du sud
un nouveau foyer de contamination est
apparue dans une église des admis les
crocs hinder chrétiens de corée s'il
vous plaît pensez à notre peuple et ne
priait pas en groupe subit cette femme
en turquie les prières dans les mosquées
sont désormais interdites
plusieurs pays en fermer écoles et
universités à gaza les courses donne
désormais à la radio ici à sintra iata
radio canada montréal